[Music]
sure this is the plate I don't see any
other monasteries on the town
it says demon
where is she who are you I'm a former
student there is a rare blue flower that
grows in the eastern slopes pick one of
these flowers if you can carry it at the
top of the mountain you may find what
you were looking for in the first place
what was I looking for only you can know
that
[Music]
where is she
who are you I'm a former student forma
which means you are not welcome here
liebe I would apologize for my students
enthusiasm but you should not have come
to this place
Wow tell ya difficult to find
hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my arrow video there was so much
Batman stuff going on it was totally a
solid there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway going on all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video such a great
Batman scene people always talk about
arrow borrowing from the Batman Dark
Knight trilogy there was actually
another scene at the end of the episode
with Talia - synced up really nicely
with the first time that ratio google
ever met with Bruce Wayne and Batman
Begins so we'll talk about that a little
bit later but there were a bunch of
comic book Easter eggs we got to talk
about the epic beatdown that they
deliver - Oliver it has been one of the
best seasons so far the only reason I
like to slay wilsonart betters because I
like the character better and they spent
more time setting the character up so it
was a bigger payoff when he came around
like holy crap it's Deathstroke from the
comics and they were friends during
season 1 now they're enemies so let's do
top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs I'll
talk about the promo - at the end of it
The Silence of the Lambs promo
but number 10 Oliver's Dark Knight
moment as he reaches the peak in the
ratio ghoul training facility from
Batman Begins which was destroyed so
what helps place the timeline of Arrow
and Batman just a little bit but you
take the multiverse into account a lot
of different things could happen so if
there is a Batman in this universe
technically Bruce Wayne should be about
the same age as Oliver so you can think
of that man as being much younger but
the problem is is that this ratio ghoul
is dead and that was a big part of the
episode - a big part of the reason that
Talia hates Oliver now so much you sort
of have to lean on multiverse Batman
theory so just like on this earth Cara
for instance there is no earth one Cara
Thor now she only exists on earth 38 so
Batman is out there somewhere they're
just doing so much Batman stuff in a
really big Easter Egg for the creation
of the arrow show so post Smallville
they were looking for a more gritty take
on a DC property so the Dark Knight
trilogy blew up so big they were like
okay we'll do a show in the tone of that
so it'll flow a lot from that energy so
that's why a lot of the early arrow
seasons felt a lot like the Batman
trilogy every once in a while they find
really fun ways to bring that back in
but number 9 the really important
takeaway here is that Talia explains
Prometheus's Adrienne chase Oliver
finally learns his secret explains her
backstory
my name is Talia al Ghul
I'm surprised that Oliver didn't take
the time to find that out before but I
guess based on the way she talks about
their previous relationship in Russia
they cut ties pretty quickly so she
didn't seem relevant at the time she was
just some person that trained Oliver he
went on he had no reason to try and
investigate her further but the thing is
is that she is training people and even
though the League of Assassins was
disbanded she makes no mention of her
sister Nyssa al Ghul or the fact that
the league is no more she just talks
about her father being dead you killed
my father prepare to suffer a lot and
then you'll die but one of the coolest
moments actually came from KGB I mean
David Nicholls a great actor but he says
his woman Talia who told you that you
need to dress your monster up and treat
it like something separate from you he's
basically making fun of Oliver being the
hood and wearing the costume who's this
Robin Hood cosplayer doing he says that
woman's out of her mind and she's going
to become the source of your greatest
pain so he was not wrong he totally told
Oliver's future during the episode the
Talia moment that I was referring to
that sort of called back to the first
time that racial goal ever met Bruce
Wayne at least in the Batman Begins
movie is the nod to being a vigilante
being that dark self you need to be
something more so ray shall go totally
shades the idea of being a vigilante
Ennis which i think is funny because
Oliver
thought of himself as a vigilante on
Talia's advice when he became the hood
before season 1 dropping all those
bodies
vigilante no no the vigilante was just a
man lost and scrambling for his own
gratification he can be destroyed or
locked up but if you make yourself a
adapter if you devote yourself to
an idea and if they stop you and you
become something else entirely
legend story but number 8 Prometheus
explains how he's ten steps ahead to had
their first confrontation in the mayor's
office and he shows Oliver how he has
control even though Oliver is the Green
Arrow he's the mayor he's so far behind
it's almost like he's been asleep this
whole time besides they're looking a
little ragged he tired eyes Geneva even
asleep this whole time so there was just
this amazing thriller element in the
episode as they started to reveal all
those things that Prometheus had thought
ahead to including the psycho mother's
house so if he was willing to kill his
wife don't you wonder what happened to
his mother so I think he loves his
mother like he actually didn't want to
kill his wife so he probably just moved
them somewhere else but Black Canary mr.
terrific using the tease fears get the
reveal and it's all just meant to draw
them out bring them to the building so
that he can capture Oliver with Talia al
Ghul but number six Oliver does try to
get his wife to help out it just because
I was expecting a twist I expected her
to be in on it but she seems pretty
genuine we didn't really get the
confirmation till the end of the episode
either number five Felicity gets in
really deep with helix but learns the
Prometheus is an alias so the real name
is Simon Morrison there is no Simon
Morrison in the comics but there is a
Simon hurt character who played a Batman
villain very much in the tone of
Prometheus during Grant Morrison's run
so you could kind of take it as an
easter egg for that and the cool thing
about the Simon hurt character in the
comics is that he took one of Bruce
Wayne's father's costumes that look kind
of like a bat in war it sort of the way
that Prometheus wears a really dark
twisted version of Oliver's costume
so a whole lot of Batman deep cuts
happening in the episode but number four
this is so badass Oliver has to trash
the Green Arrow about breaking into
Prometheus house right in front of him
in 24 hours there's going to be orders
to shoot to kill so he has to do all
this while he's standing there with his
wife so intense they did such a good job
of building WTF to the climax of the
episode where he ends up killing his
wife number 3 Prometheus takes out
Captain Pike neutralizing Oliver's play
against them and you thought he did his
homework he actually knows about shado
from the island which seems like it'd be
relatively secret there aren't that many
people that know that shadow exists
between Slade and Oliver you think this
is a game I don't feel like playing
anyone you don't have a choice either if
you kill me you kill Susan and she will
be as dead as your mother I care problem
I call dead because of you so you start
to wonder where he got that information
like who's he been talking to
Deathstroke is still alive out there
somewhere but number two getting even
crazier team arrow rescue Susan rolling
in like a boss but they're bombs
everywhere or sink Prometheus to kill
his wife who it did seem like he had
genuine feelings for like it does seem
like he cared about her but he is so
driven on his mission to make Oliver
suffer that she is secondary so you're
going to tell the police you're the weak
link okay I'm going to get rid of the
weak link and then later he finds a way
to pin it on Oliver
stepping up to them inside the police
station oh hi long time no see
how you been but the fight was epic in
number one one of my favorite moments in
the episode
Talia comes back helps capture all of
her claiming that he must suffer
she has been so hardcore so don't you
feel like Nyssa is due for a guest
appearance to take her out now that
might not happen team arrow might have
to take her out on their own but if
anybody is going to come back they did
say that they were trying to get
somebody special to come back at the
last couple of episodes they sent them
an offer so I'm hoping that it's Nyssa
al Ghul and she sort of neutralized
Talia and they can do something with
them in season six but here's the
Silence of the Lambs style promo for the
next episode
professor secret Oliver in all this
heads actually
in fact every life you touch your son
[Music]
well forth in their honor so you see all
these pictures in the background it's
going to be an epic beatdown with them
inside this cell for forty two minutes
just him torturing Oliver till he goes
crazy what do you want for me so this is
so great I totally love what arrow is
doing right now let me know what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and do you think that it's possible for
this season to top the Deathstroke arc
from season two if they don't have
Deathstroke available if he ever shows
up again all bets are off but what's
going to happen next is is there's a
couple Marvel videos I'll be posting new
guardians of the galaxy footage they
confirm that there's going to be a third
Guardians film and then I have New
Avengers infinity war Infinity Gauntlet
stuff to post so I'll try to get that
out as fast as possible congratulations
to the latest flash ring giveaway winner
a lot of Jack please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video on
ounce the winner the next time I post a
DC video while you wait for that stuff
to post you can click here for this
week's flash and you can click here for
next week's flash thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video